Richard and Ben have spent an uneasy
night on the edge of a million
settlement expecting a possible attack
from an isolated Indian tribe it's now
morning there's no sign of intrusion and
everyone is safe at the combo village
but downriver an arraylist was attacked
Nikita got off their kill my voltages
bajo quote there was a high Bank s a
flash at here premier flash this was the
first arrow they fired from the bank
into authorized mushy coke it landed
behind Chicago school policies Marta
Nakano it hit the boat you can see the
tips bro quanta quebrada laughs we're
not come here yeah so ducky I looked up
and saw this one coming
aah honk lady our two same jalawla I
leaned bath and it passed in front of us
and hit the water
meliss returns to the attack site to
have a look around
Gustav you Carlon ability bhajami rola
Yaffe spell dog apostle opera rap Akane
Morales believes that isolated natives
shouldn't be fired at when they attack
and it should be left to them to make
contact
yosh kids Debra Messing's Olas Boulevard
they should remain isolated for several
reasons we know from statistics that
when you contact tribes like this
2/3 of the population died after 2 years
doughy sénèque wonton too generous so
it's not contact it's genocide she
wouldn't want you now I guess it's a
matter of respect
CSS wolves if these people are they're
isolated in the forest don't get why not
respect their right to do this stage
give state
the isolated Indians are being forced
into ever smaller regions these NASA
satellite pictures show how logging is
decimating the forests
Peru has owned over 70% of its Amazonian
rainforest for oil and gas exploration
rainforest harvesting brings more road
construction into the forest which
provides easy access for illegal loggers
Morales hopes that by proving the
existence of the uncontacted tribes and
making the public aware of them will
improve their chances of survival